ce que vous aimez les incroyables est-ce
que vous en fichez j'ai l'impression que
vous êtes endormi
merci les chéris sachez que les
chroniqueurs aussi ont des talents et
oui ils ont des talents ce soir et je
vais demander je vais demander je vais
prendre deux personnes du public
deux personnes du public qui vont faire
le jury aujourd'hui encore qui veut
faire le jury d'incroyable talent alors
je veux une fille et un garçon
voilà bah venait comme ça on est
directement au mercy et
comment vous appelez marina marina sarah
marina tape un petit carré veut pas
lâcher la barre et la tuque à nous de
ponthierry à côté de melun seine et
marne s'est un peu loupé je sais pas
trop d'où tu viens
je me cherche encore alors marié fiancée
au populaire concubinage avec les gants
les amène avec lui la balle qui était
pas mal ces six nations c'est chasse
gardée ben ça va
bon je passais par là quelques
cacahuètes mais c'est tout sauf ça va et
ça fait quand même temps que tu avec 8,8
en fait quoi dans la vie coiffeuse non
j'adore explique le carré j'aime bien
question pensent de moi capillairement
c'est pas mal tu aimes bien c'est bien
là bas on y ait un bon délire way est
bien tombée aussi une barbe ses mémoires
mais combien ouais ouais tu vas adorer
jean michel maire mais je ne sais pas
pas sûr non je ne pense pas et lui sert
gaulle et nous la joie ou l'autre bout
soir à lui bonsoir ça va bien alors tu
compte intégrer le groupe indochine
non j'ai mon micro ah oui c'est vrai
c'est bon on ne parle pas comme ça ça va
comment tu t'habitues nicolas nicolas
sava nicolas oui tu fais quoi dans la
vie je suis apprentie apprentis quoi
pâtissier pâtissier j'adore c'est quoi
ta spécialité
les macarons les macarons les macarons
ah ouais tu peux pas ne peut pas aller
acheter dès qu'est ce qui te faut là
pour faire des macarons non mais j'ai
pas le temps j'ai un truc à fond
michael cherry bomb installez-vous
l'échec d'aller faire le jury
d'incroyable talent qu'un magali
attention on va accueillir notre premier
talent de la soirée notre premier talent
de la soirée c'est une danseuse de pole
dance
je vous demande d'accueillir salle qui
motif de ouf
ludivine rhétorique sebha
[Applaudissements]
normalement c'est très satisfaisant pole
dance avec moi ça sera pour moi chila
des barytons sur le conviant après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la tête qui tourne en pierre
excuse moi on se passera t commenté
[Musique]
jean-michel
notre jury et voilà c'est ça tu sais moi
alors c'est le golden buzzer non
franchement c'était des catastrophes a
déconné mais un drame
''j'en initiation j'ai quand même elles
tournent elles tournent tous remercient
joly moi ça m'a plu elle tourne elle
tourne moi j'ai rien vu tourner la
lunette sociaux comme on les trouve
magali s'en lasse pas c'était pas mal
mais on voit que c'est un début mais
c'est bien on peut dire que c'est ta
merde non merci on dire attaque je pense
qu'on peut lire c'était de la merde mais
avec l'âge et michel je pense était une
journée noire pour l'histoire de la
pologne aura un avant et un après c'est
pathétique
merci merci le 2ème talent pas si on
peut les appeler ainsi c'est notre ami
benjamin castaldi et son numéro de
ventriloquie
[Applaudissements]
bonjour comment tu t'appelles dont même
le cadreur regarder ouazine qui tiennent
bien la table et gentille
c'est pas si mal mais c'est pas si mal
oui oui la nana je sais ce qui se passe
est un jour ma gueule qu'est ce qu'un
quoi ce cas là c'est particulièrement de
la merde mais vrai c'est ma maison
vraiment c'était pas si mal mais bon
c'est très bien et on prendre trop de la
fin des temps le micro ouais c'était pas
terrible c'était pas très bien troisième
3d un numéro c'est un numéro à 2 c'est
un numéro de magie maintenant maxime
gagny et kelly vdo velits
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis pas fou mais une bête une
musique comme ça ce que c'est un tour de
magie totalement feelgood a donc pu
arrêter la musique mais ça sera très
sympa abandon c'est pas sans celle du
ascensionnel je vais recadrer la
personne les groupes lors alors ça vient
de faire un nom mais faut le faire aux
téléspectateurs mesdames messieurs je
vais vous faire un petit tour de magie
avec deux boules d'accord bah c'est la
première fois qu'il va s'en servir comme
ça comme ça e
le but du jeu est assez sa mort et une
balle rouler deux minutes enrichi et les
shérifs juste des chats qu'on a du mal à
le comprendre si vous rajoutez du piano
en plus un léger fond voilà c'est ça une
balle d'accord cette balle je la mets
dans ma mère d'accord kelly tu vas
prendre l'autre mal tu la fermes a vu
une balle une balle égalité entre les
deux tu souffles sur la mienne
disparaissions la balle au vote ama et
de bâle sont pas si je vais vous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne
exceptionnellement pour tpm p on veut de
la balle lorsque vous l'a placé à
l'intérieur des secrètement ou toucher
les deux doigts et là elle passe ça
c'est boire leur faire faire année
la balle la balle ici d'act up
ça passe pour complexifier le tour tu
prends une troisième balle une deux
trois tu admets train à gauche en étuve
à souffler le plus fort possible souffle
hélas rien
vous savez c'est le bal le format télé
normale dans le slip deux amis et non
dans le décolleté non non je déconne
la chute s'est terminée sur sa merci
[Applaudissements]
alors franchement là c'est pas mal oui
sectionnelles estoniens sur me kelly
mckee malaxer les boules parfait j'ai
pas compris à conserver le maximum mais
qu'il est très bonne excuse lit très
bonne il a raison excusez moi non mais
calmez vous quand vous allez parler
comme ça tout les mois ça va s'arranger
l'écran